what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the full extent of
Austin's post time skip power up which
has just been beautifully showcased in
the black clover story on top of that I
will be talking about the true nature of
Asta's anti-magic and the power of the
demon inside his grimoire as the story
has progressed we have been slowly
learning more about Asta's demon and it
appears that the demon's true powers
have been steadily awakening inside
hasta this became especially apparent
during the fight against the kotodama
devil and now as the spade kingdom arc
swings into full gear we are seeing a
true awakening of austin's demon powers
personally I find this aspect of black
clover extremely interesting and that is
exactly what I will be talking about in
this video if you enjoyed the black
clover content right here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't make sure to click that Bell and
check off the option that says all
notifications you're gonna miss a lot of
our videos
it's just how YouTube works a big thank
you to all of our anime upper patrons
who make videos like this one possible
if you want to check out our patreon and
become a member of the anime our team
you can click the link right there in
the description finally there will be
black clover manga spoilers in this
video I will be dealing with the latest
developments in the story so if you're
not caught up to the manga please
proceed with caution you have been
warned as chapter 230 begins we are
thrown right back into the action inside
the mobile fortress hasta is just
throwing the Spade Kingdom soldiers
around like ragdolls and after he's
already ruined the day of every single
soldier in the immediate area
hasta introduces himself to the
civilians as hasta of the black balls a
magic knight of the clover Kingdom he
tells the civilians that he's not here
to hurt them and that they will be safe
from now on but hasta soon realizes that
the spirit of the civilians has been
completely broken by the spade Kingdom
pterri the civilians explained that they
are only being kept alive so that their
mana can power the mobile fortress and
they are unable to leave the fortress
even if they could leave they couldn't
survive outside because they are
currently inside a grand magic zone and
they are all too weak to withstand such
power the girl who was attacked by the
military officer just moments earlier
explains that they the civilians didn't
want anything to do with this war they
were forced into it by the military and
they had no say in the matter
the girl explains that the commander of
the fortress is a horrible man with
terrifying mana and a grotesque
disgusting power and it is clear from
their demeanor that all the civilians
inside the fortress are truly afraid of
the commander asked to decides that in
order to put the civilians at ease he
must crush every last one of the Spade
Kingdom soldiers inside the fortress and
he sets out to do exactly that as more
soldiers rush in to confront hasta he
dispatches them promptly with the
diamond dwellers sword and no matter
what they do the soldiers cannot stand
up to us as immense anti magic power
during this battle asta shows off
another epic skill he starts dual
wielding with incredible ease and he
smashes his opponents with the diamond
dwellers sword in one hand and the demon
Slayers sword in the other I really
enjoyed seeing hasta in action in this
chapter
asta has always been strong because of
his sheer drive and determination but
now it really feels like he is combining
his physical strength and determination
with good technique something that he
definitely hadn't perfected up to this
point
finally the fortress commander appears
unsurprisingly he is a creepy man with
batshit crazy eyes and he realizes right
away that hasta has the power of a demon
dwelling inside him hasta demands to
know how the commander could do such
terrible things to his own people the
innocent civilians of the Spade Kingdom
but the commander doesn't seem to
understand hasta it's like they're
speaking a totally different language
the Spade Kingdom commander believes
that it is completely normal to treat
those who have low magic levels as
nothing
more than sacrifices for the prosperity
of the Spade Kingdom and he is acting as
if the civilians should be honored that
they can be useful to the Spade Kingdom
by sacrificing their bodies and their
lives for the greater good
hasta is furious when he hears all this
after all he was born as a commoner
himself and he was born in the forsaken
realm so he has been treated as inferior
his entire life by people with higher
social standing but before hasta can
teach the commander an important lesson
in respecting all people regardless of
magic tear or social status a terrible
dark rash breaks out all over Austin's
body asta realizes that the commander
possesses a particularly aggressive and
grotesque form of poison magic called
poison creation magic the commander
marks hasta because his complete lack of
mana means that he couldn't even be
sacrificed to power the mobile fortress
so he is a totally useless life-form as
far as the military is concerned but
asta has had enough he summons the demon
destroyer sword and he uses its special
ability to absorb and remove the effects
of the commander's poison magic from his
body the commander is shocked when he
sees this and he can't believe that
someone like asta with no magic could
possess such incredible power Austin now
has all three swords out and ready to go
and he promises to crush all the
soldiers inside the fortress as he gears
up the fully powered up version of black
divider hasta is furious about the fact
that the Spade kingdom treats its own
citizens so horribly and he decides that
he will not hold back any longer we are
about to witness the full extent to last
us new post time skip power boost as the
chapter ends we see the text a slash
that Cleaves even through the fortress
itself written on the final panel and
above the mobile fortress we see a
massive specter of Austin's demon
looking down on the fortress from above
this image of Austin demon is probably
more symbolic but I thought that this
chapter was extremely interesting we
learned more about dissipate Kingdom and
their mentality and we also got to see
just how much hasta has progressed in
these last
six months the spade kingdom army
definitely reminds me of Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood with all that
sacrifice business and if you don't get
that reference you definitely need to
watch Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
because it is amazing as this arc of
black Laura progresses we may learn that
mega Cola actually has many similarities
to the main villain of Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood as well and I
really look forward to learning more
about mega Cola in particular this
strongest demon who allegedly killed
Noelle's mother and then went on to
control an entire kingdom is still such
a huge mystery and I can't wait to see
his character design and to learn more
about his true intentions and
motivations in these last few chapters
we also learned that Auster's control of
his anti magic abilities has improved
dramatically
he now has much better technique and he
is now able to perform his strongest
attacks without even entering the black
asked the form which is important
because when he entered this form in the
past the amount of time he could stay in
it was limited and the amount of times
that he could access this form within a
specific period of time was also limited
at this point asked his control of anti
magic and his ability to use all three
swords effectively are on a whole other
level and it is clear that asta trained
incredibly hard during these past six
months which is exactly what we would
expect from asta it is also possible
that Asta's bond with the demon inside
his grimoire has developed during this
time this would explain Asta's ability
to tap into his anti magic more easily
and it would also explain that final
panel where austin's demon is shown
towering over the entire fortress as if
to say that he is now truly awakening
and unleashing his full power I expected
the final battle of this heart will be a
battle of the demons with hasta and
osdas demon facing off against Meggie
Kula I am a bit disappointed that we
didn't learn anything new about the man
who came to search for you know and who
appeared in the previous chapter but
overall I still thought that this
chapter had great action and valuable
information about Oster's power and the
Spade Kingdom let me know what you guys
think do you think that Asta's bond with
his demon is improving and is his demon
about to awaken to his true potential
and if this is the case
what will this mean for hasta what kind
of new powers abilities or attacks could
ask to develop in the near future feel
free to give me your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more black
lower content right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for supporting
our work and making videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh baby rain nothing but
a fan Jason Wilson King's eldress $30
beat garage Gian Anatole Cassatt's key
DJ Nathaniel alpha do and on hell crews
and of course I can't forget our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including Ingrid ah
a lowland out of Maddy Mac makoto-kun
Seth Cooper and the world and you know
he's serious because he didn't say so
wild doll if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
please consider becoming a patron even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]